so our geniuses in washington spent 20
years in afghanistan with no clearly
defined mission
then they decided to pick a college
professor to run the country to run
afghanistan a college pressure guy just
like them turns out to be every bit as
corrupt as they are in the end and then
they get in a way that's almost
calculated to humiliate and diminish the
united states most disastrous exit from
anything in 250 years
so they look around they say hmm how can
we make this a little bit worse i have
an idea let's import some rapists that
would make it even worse than we've
already made it
and they have the washington times
reported today that he previously
deported rapists was among the afghan
refugees that just landed at dulles
airport of course let's import rapists
because it's not bad enough
congressman tom tiffany recently toured
fort mccoy in wisconsin where 2 000
afghan evacuees are being held he says
he did not see a single special
immigrant visa holder he also says that
all of the evacuees were free to leave
the base whenever they wanted to
congressman tiffany joins us tonight
congressman thanks so much for coming on
um first of all thank you for seeing
this for yourself tell us what you saw
so we've seen the debacle in afghanistan
and it appears the biden administration
is going to double down on it by
bringing people who are unvetted into
our country i was at fort mccoy in
southwestern wisconsin last friday where
there were 2 000 evacuees from
afghanistan
and what we found out is none of them
were there on a special immigration visa
they were all there on parole and for
our listeners
the special immigration visa
is a thorough vetting process that can
take up to two years to find out if a
person should be coming united states
the parole authority is granted to the
secretary of the department of homeland
security and he could just wave people
in they have circumvented the biden
administration has circumvented the siv
process and they're just bringing people
in on parole second thing that we saw
tucker was that people could leave the
base including without the authority of
the general that is overseeing fort
mccoy
so we've got two islands off the coast
i'm not talking about guantanamo bay i'm
talking about nantucket and martha's
vineyard and i don't think any of these
refugees have been moved to nantucket or
martha's vineyard they've all been moved
to places like wisconsin and maine and
like far away from the centers of power
is there anything we can do to change
that if we're going to import thousands
of unvetted afghan pashtun tribesmen why
aren't we moving them to the places
where the people who make these
decisions live
well that would really be a good idea
but what i have suggested and there are
afghans that should be able to come into
our country i've talked to servicemen in
my district who said there are people
that should be able to come from
afghanistan because
they
they've given their
some of them have given their almost
their lives being threatened by the
taliban and they should be able to come
to the united states however these
people are not being vetted thoroughly
and what should happen is they should go
to a third uh a safe third country like
qatar some place like that and be vetted
there and then if they get through the
vetting they should be able to come in
because 84 of the people that in the
first quarter of this year that tried to
get an siv in afghanistan they were
rejected only 16 percent were able to
get in there has to be a thorough
vetting process the biden administration
is circumventing it
yeah they're just using a crisis to
change our country they'll never lose
another election that's the point
as you know congressman thanks so much i
appreciate you coming on tonight